so the the legal system begins with a
schema or a story or an understanding of
what the human animal is and what moves
people and it is a very familiar story
it's the same kind of schema that is
common sensical that that research has
that researchers have shown most
Americans have about what moves us and
that is a very simple kind of set of
stable preferences that we have and we
take those stable preferences and we use
our ability to think and we gather
information and we combine our thinking
and our preferences apply a little bit
of our will and that leads to our
choices are action so the simple model
that is fundamental to kind of classical
liberalism fundamental to the legal
system fundamental to loan economics is
that I call that the disposition 'used
actor model that individuals are moving
are being moved by their own preferences
their own disposition you might call it
a characterological model or an
individualistic model there are
different names you might give it I call
it disposition 'used that view of the
person turns out to be absolutely
fundamental to every legal question that
comes up because legal questions are
focused on what happens when something
goes wrong or what happens when
something goes right how are we going to
split up what happened between the
parties who are involved and and our
answers to those questions turn on
attributions we make about who played a
more significant causal role what were
their motives what were their intentions
and so forth in answering those
questions and the view of the person
carries much of the weight in terms of
determining the answer so if we see
someone acting and behaving in a certain
way and we conclude that that's because
of their preferences and we conclude in
turn that as a consequence of their
actions they're fulfilling their
preferences then from a legal
perspective our view is let's not
intervene
they're pursuing their own welfare so if
we see individuals eating a lot of food
cheeseburgers milkshakes and french
fries we say they must really like that
food and if they become obese we say
that's what you get you need to you know
for eating like that you've got to
change your behavior if you want to
avoid that what what the mind Sciences
suggest is that this basic model of the
human animal is fundamentally wrong
which is not to say that the that people
don't have some agency it's not to say
that people can't make some choices
based on something but it's not based on
a stable set of preferences to which we
give normative weight and and much of
the behaviors influences influenced by
forces within us that were not conscious
of and around us so that if you go back
to that same person who is obese and you
look at their situation you begin to see
it's more than just an individual's
choices based on their proclivity for
milkshakes and if you want to understand
an obesity epidemic you've got to look
outside of that simple model which again
mind scientists have shown is incorrect
and begin looking at the situation from
a law perspective it's not just a claim
that gee what you're doing is is wrong
from and inaccurate it's that if you
care about problems such as the obesity
epidemic or smoking or you name the
problem that your focus on the
dispositions of the individuals involved
is not going to help you solve the
problem at most it's going to create an
illusion that there is no problem
because people chose it or the problem
is solved because whatever whoever the
bad apple is the bad actor is has been
punished or fined or put in prison so
that the dispositional eclipses the
situation eclipses some of the
opportunities that we might have to
actually make changes in laws in customs
and institutions
change outcomes
I was interested in for
number of reasons one is that I started
as a so-called legal economist so when I
was hired 18 years ago at Harvard I came
in as a lone economic scholar and like
other law and economics scholars I was
applying the the so-called rational
actor model to legal questions but even
at that point I was I was highly
doubtful about the accuracy and the
relevance of that model for a number of
reasons one is that before before going
to law school I had spent a year on a
fellowship in London actually all of all
of Britain but first six months of it
was in London when I attended the sort
of the daily rounds with the doctors at
various large London neonatal intensive
care units and the question I was asking
as a young budding scholar was how is it
that these doctors decide which of the
the neonates the premature babies and
the babies that need a great deal of
care both nursing care and special
equipment how do they decide which of
those babies are going to get care given
that the National Health Service at the
time had to know how had the equipment
had the ability to take care of kids but
didn't have enough resources to do it
for all of them so I was studying first
that question in the neonatal intensive
care units the sort of really first-rate
medical facilities in London and then i
traveled around England including rural
areas and went to various pediatric
hospitals and units to find out what
sorts of decisions they were faced with
there and what I came to understand was
that the kind of rational actor model
the way we make choices in the wood it's
very it's very different that that on
one hand a health economist might say
this is the way you maximise life years
and yet when you went to the health care
system that had to make what Guido
Calabresi my few
teacher called tragic choices between
infants all of whom needed care but only
some of whom could get it that this idea
of maximizing life years was actually
foreign unusual may be insulting to the
people who were involved and instead
other factors were influencing and if
which of the infants got got care so
when I came to law school with that with
that training and economics on one hand
but that insight that rational actor
model just really wasn't capturing
important questions I brought that to my
studies as a law student I I continued
though in the law and economics
tradition and then as a young scholar
here at Harvard I began writing about a
question that was pretty much resolved
in the law which was the question of
whether tobacco manufacturers should be
held liable for the consequences of
their of their products in terms of lung
cancer heart disease and and so forth
the resolution had been clear that for
most of the 20th century the answer was
no sure you can try to bring a case but
you were going to lose it and when legal
theorists asked the question and
particularly when legal economists asked
the question the answer was the not just
no but it should be no normatively
that's the right result and that's true
because smokers are choosing freely to
smoke and given the sort of premises of
law and economics which assumes that if
you're choosing something freely and you
are informed of the risk that you must
be better off as a consequence and after
you reach that conclusion is really
nothing else the law shouldn't engage
with then the theory led to the
conclusion that we shouldn't do anything
I was skeptical of that for some of the
same reasons that I had
I had grown skeptical of the sort of the
rational actor model in the healthcare
context generally and began studying
really what is the nature of the choice
to smoke and in that process also began
studying the documents that the
manufacturers had and we're just
beginning to come out as whistleblowers
and others spirit of the spirit of them
away and sent them to lawyers lawyers
started sending them to me and I ended
up with a office full of tobacco
documents and spent the better part of a
year with with some research assistants
and future co-authors going through
those documents and trying to understand
what the industry thought about the
smoker and the choice to smoke at the
end of that process I I came to the
conclusion that the industry was telling
us one thing telling us that we were
choosers and that and that we smoked
because we wanted to because it tasted
good because it's satisfied us us and
gave us pleasure but internally they
were saying the reasons that people
smoke are very different and they
actively attempted to influence the
behavior of their consumers and
potential consumers with that knowledge
and some of the most important knowledge
they used was psychology that that sort
of realization and that work in that
area led me to more or less abandoned
law and economics in the rational actor
model and to put everything down and two
to take a couple of years and start
teaching myself social psychology social
cognition and other mind sciences so
that's a bit of the transition or what
led me to this approach
you